darlington and his investigation of a
military research installation in
southern nevada known as area 51. you
know anyone could say that about using
any classified program but now a look at
the life and work of irish poet william
butler yates
f foster discusses his biography of the
poet called wb yates a life the first
volume of the work is subtitled the
apprentice mage 1865-1914
in the book mr foster looks at yates
poetry and also his careers as
journalist playwright and political
figure rf foster has written several
books of history and biography he spoke
at the 92nd street y in new york city
my
good morning ladies and gentlemen
i'm carl cartway director of the 92nd
street wise underberg poetry center and
i'd like to welcome you to the third in
this year's series of biographers and
brunch lectures this morning
distinguished irish historian roy foster
will speak to us about the life and work
of william butler yates
i also wanted to remind you that on
sunday morning january 25th at 11
o'clock here in the art gallery english
poet and critic andrew motion will speak
about his new life of john keats i hope
you'll attend
for those of you joining us for the
first time this morning i might say a
word about format mr foster will speak
about yates's life and work for about 50
minutes after which he will respond to
10 or 15 minutes of questions from the
audience following this we invite you to
partake of a light brunch which will be
served in the so-called hall of mirrors
just outside
there too you will find copies of mr
foster's yates biography on sale i
should add that c-span is here this
morning taping this lecture for their
about books program and we welcome them
roy foster refers to that collection of
writings comprising yates's
autobiographies as a disingenuous
masterpiece and indeed i think there
have been few documents in the history
of modern poetry which are more
fascinating or less reliable
in an installment of those
autobiographies called the trembling of
the veil which refers to a period in the
poet's life covered by the first volume
of mr foster's biography we find the
following passage by yates quote
when we are dead according to my belief
we live our lives backward for a certain
number of years treading the paths that
we have trodden growing young again even
childish again until some attain an
innocence that is no mere accident of
nature but the human intellect's
crowning achievement
it was at cool that the first few simple
thoughts that now grown complex through
their contact with other thoughts
explain the world came to me
unquote
poor old yates still simplifying as wh h
auden ironically remarks in james
merrill's epic poem based on
conversations at a ouija board
mr foster observes that the
autobiographies are devoted to asserting
personality through gesture and
identifying development by strictly
defined epiphanies
we may smile at the philosophy and
mysticism behind that quotation of yates
but there is something haunting about it
too
what is more it is a perfect capsule
description of the achievement of roy
foster's ongoing biography truly epic in
scope of which the first of two volumes
the apprentice mage appeared this year
for what mr foster does is to walk us
back to the beginning of that chameleon
artist's life we see yates as ernest
reese did around 1887 quote a very pale
exceedingly thin young man with a raven
lock over his forehead his face so
narrow that there was hardly room in it
for his luminous black eyes unquote
through mr foster's biography we
understand not only the old miracle that
a supreme artistic genius should have
emerged from the muddle of yates's
unstable childhood and early family life
but also the difficulty of fixing that
life in any reliable interpretive way
once it had come to consciousness or
perhaps we should say self-consciousness
for as mr foster remarks one of yates's
gifts was an uncanny ability to predict
posterity's reaction to him for a man of
masks this deepened the play of writing
his own history but for a historian and
biographer it makes establishing the
truth of that history surpassingly
difficult
the great contribution of mr foster's
biography is that it does fix that life
and the work that life produced as no
other biography has quite done between
and among the historical events to which
that life aspired and it does this by
presenting the facts but not necessarily
by imposing the biographer's opinion
upon them
an epic of service to the subject
sheamus heaney called this biography in
a recent review a mighty argussy of
scholarship
when i was an undergraduate in the late
1970s beginning the study of yates the
triad of authors to which i was directed
was helen wendler thomas whitaker and
harold bloom critics all of them but why
not biographers one might have added
joseph hohn or norman jeffers or richard
ellman one might even have added dennis
donahoe who has also spoken about yates
in this biographers and brunch series
but from this moment whomever else one
reads for clarification of the life and
work of this poet one will be obliged to
read roy foster first it is an honor to
welcome him here now
[Applause]
thank you very much carl for those
generous words and thank you all for
coming here on a
fine sunday morning to hear a historian
not a critic not a poet alas talk about
yates
i think i have a certain excuse for this
for being a historian writing and
talking about this poet and a
a certain
sanction as well
that comes from my
subject in old age yates went to visit
the municipal gallery in dublin
and was overcome to see there the the
portraits of the friends of his youth
all of them by now dead lady gregory
singh
and company
and he wrote a poem about it which ends
with a celebrated yatzian
and yates's poetry is full of
instructions
some of which should be taken very
seriously
you that would judge me do not judge
alone this book or that come to this
hallowed place where my friends
portraits hang and look they're on
ireland's history in their lineaments
trace
think where a man's glory most begins
and ends and say my glory was i had such
friends
now it's that last couplet that gets
quoted most and i think it's rather pity
because i think it's
uncharacteristically
trite and characteristically
disingenuous we knew perfectly well his
glory came from other sources than the
people who wear his friends but the line
before it fascinates me ireland's
history in their lineaments trace yates
knew that national history in ireland
perhaps more than anywhere is
traced through
individuals through emblematic figures
and he knew he was one such and i want
really to talk today about
yates in history
yates as emblem yates as witness and
actor in the drama of irish history
because he lives all these lives he
lives the life of journalist politician
revolutionary theater director
polemicist
as well as writing poems
and his public status in ireland became
became iconic
especially after the 1916 rising and the
subsequent revolution against british
rule into which yates reinserted himself
after a period when he had in fact
become as i think disillusioned with
irish nationalism however he became the
national poet with independence in the
1920s he became a big uh smiling public
man as he put it and a senator in the
free state and all of that but he never
relinquished a combat of relationship
with irish history with irish life with
irish politics what he called in one of
his great essays a continual quarrel and
a continual apology
and controversy
is is is all about him through his life
he ends
his life as a great but controversial
public figure
smiling public man is only half of it
perhaps because of this the project of
an authorized biography took a long time
to come about and went through many
vicissitudes
and um
perhaps because of this to the yates
family were determined quite early on to
choose a historian to write it
um
so there if you like are my credentials
but yates isn't the only poet who gives
who
sanctions this approach to his life t.s
eliot famously said that you couldn't
understand yates without understanding
his times and you couldn't understand
his times without understanding yates
it's fascinating i think to remember
that yates whom we think of in such a
modernist framework began
as a victorian a late victorian
he's a revolutionary in more ways than
one because he's the irish victorian who
becomes the irish modernist he makes his
name in the late 80s and 90s with celtic
twilight dim blue and silver effects
and a certain decadent flavor which
makes him controversial in ireland it's
fascinating to think that he not only is
operating at the same time as aubry
birdsley william morris the whole circle
of ninety-ish people but he knows them
he is always drawn to dramatic people he
has an almost
um supernatural affinity for finding and
knowing the people who will themselves
emblematize the history of their day
he's
forever throwing off terrific theatrical
effects in his poetry as you know in
that of course i think he's very
unlike elias the other i think great
figure of poetry and english in that
area i always think it was virginia
woolf who said that
referring to some forthcoming social
event tom elliott will be there in a
four-piece suit and that idea of being
buttoned up completely is terribly
unlike yates who is
floppy ties and expansive gestures and
the life lived as art
and lived theatrically his life is full
of scene changes
um drama announcements personal
statements and the poetry
which often
seems deceptively autobiographical
often carries a charge that isn't
immediately apparent i think this is
true from the very early poetry and to
look at his first poems the poems that
made his reputation
the poems that made irish history
culture celtic imagery fashionable
that made it accessible to
an english and indeed an international
market one could look perhaps at a
perfect little poem the song of
wandering angus i went out to the hazel
wood because a fire was in my head and
cut and peeled a hazel wand and hooked a
berry to a thread
and when white moths were on the wing
and moth-like stars were flickering out
i dropped the berry in a stream and
caught a little silver trout
when i had laid it on the floor i went
to blow the fire of flame but something
rustled on the floor and someone called
me by my name it had become a glimmering
girl with apple blossom in her hair who
called me by my name and ran and faded
through the brightening air
though i am old with wandering through
hollow lands and hilly lands i will find
out where she has gone and take her lips
and kiss her hands and walk among long
dapple grass and pluck till time and
times are done the silver apples of the
moon the golden apples of the sun
which when you know that apple blossom
is his code for mod gone which when you
see it as a poem about the irish god of
love angus seems a love poem on a
rarefied level however it could also be
seen oddly as a political poem because
it's following a gaelic genre of poetry
called ashling poetry which is about
ireland appearing as a visionary woman
to a poet who represents the the the
country in enthrall and the woman offers
liberation these are jacobite poems
really from the 18th century and i think
yates is consciously using that
political
form of gaelic poetry
to fuse it with in this case a love poem
and a poem about mysticism
he's always
at his most deceptive when he's at his
most
simple and the longer i've worked on the
more i admire those early poems even a
little
poem of quatrains like the fiddler of
dooney which seems
like
almost insubstantial when i play on my
fiddle in dooney folk dance like a wave
of the sea my cousin is priest and
kilvarnat my brother in maher of we
i passed by my brother and cousin they
read in their books of prayer i read in
my book of songs i bought at the sligo
fair
the place names are manipulated the
lovely dance rhythm is there but it's
also slightly exotic and the poem goes
on to argue
that the good are always the merry saved
by an evil chance i love that
qualification and to argue that
merriment and poetry and art
are or should be
prioritized over religion
when he enters heaven the fiddler enters
heaven before his priestly relatives
it's
very much
an accessible way of saying what yates
was saying in his essays at this exactly
this time in the 80s early 90s that the
poet must become the priest of a new
cultural revolution in a sense so
there's uh a depth to this
um deceptive little poem too
and it's interesting to notice that this
is the kind of poetry which he doesn't
expel from his canon as he expels so
much of his early poetry ruthlessly
takes it out of the published
collections rewrites it if it's to stay
there continually reassesses his canon
but the fiddler of dooney stays and is
put as the signature poem at the end of
a key collection and he he's still in
fact reciting it in
um archival recordings of the bbc in the
late 1930s so it shows that i think he
knows that it was central to his verve
and those early poems which he kept in
his cannon have have have a clue i think
to his his development because he
becomes tired of more predictable celtic
twilight effects from the turn of the
century he's looking for a harder
cleaner
newer note
he's experimenting with the strangely
conversational idiom he brings into his
poems
the
deliberate modernity which ezra pound
used to claim that he had helped to
sculpt into yates's poetry but which i
think yates was moving towards before
pound began working with him as he did
work with him on the drafts of some of
his poems
and the influence of this kind of
diction is one of the things that
qualifies him i suppose as as a
modernist
he goes on to help the young james joyce
to collaborate further with pound to
write poetry i think of astonishing
grandeur and mystery
finally in the 30s though he returns to
those
simple forms and the ballad meters and
the
strange shock effects of his late poetry
can be linked back i think to some of
his earliest experiments
certainly the strangely jagged
sensual discordant note seems new but i
don't think it's entirely new now if you
compare this side that that's a rather
detune and and and hurried run through
the great um development of yates's
poetry but if you compare this to
elliot's consistent rather austere
development and avoidance of drama
it's again i think instructive
another way in which they're different
is the question of public life
because
yates i think is unlike any other poet
in the english language except possibly
milton who lives a violently engaged
public life
it's always an irish identification
though he spends part of the year always
in london and indeed in the first half
of his life which i've now published
about he really lives in england more
than in ireland which comes
came as rather a surprise to me at least
so i hope as a surprise to others as
well
but it's worth plotting this irish life
against the history of his times he's
born in the mid-1860s just when the
class from which he comes the protestant
so-called ascendancy is entering decline
it's losing its privileged hold on the
the reigns of power economically
socially and politically
and as so often and i think russian
history will show us this too a
revolutionary will come from
the ranks of a declining elite
but they are that ascendancy protestant
class though not the possessors of big
houses and hunters and
um family portraits and all that they're
from
social which provides civil servants
clerics the sort of middle-ranking
echelons of the ascendancy
and he ate his father dramatically and
family mode turns his back on this
embarks on the life of a portrait
painter lives in london's artistic
bohemia
very poor
they're the sort of people who when
people come to tea in the afternoons
they have to borrow money from them and
send one of the kids out the back to buy
the tea and sugar for this is an actual
incident recorded one of yates's sisters
diaries the father is i think a fine
painter
but he can never finish a painting
his son learns by his mistakes and i
think it's very interesting that
dramatic closure
is
the signature of a yates poem so often a
yates bomb could end no other way than
the way it ends
if you think of your favorite yates
poems i think you'll realize that a
ringing conclusion that is utterly
right no matter how surprising
and interestingly when yates can't
finish something and there are certain
plays like the player queen which or the
shadowy waters which go on and on and on
for years and years or his
autobiographical novel the speckled bird
when he can't finish something it always
has a very autobiographical content that
piece of work so there's something
interesting happening there as well
when he does produce his first great
public success it is
again a poem with an autobiographical
charge and it's a poem significantly
written in london but about emigration
the lake isle of innisfree
i will arise and go now and go to finish
free and a small cabin bill there of
clay and wattles made
nine bean rows will i have there a hive
for the honey bee and live alone in the
bee loud
and i shall have some peace there for
peace comes dropping slow
dropping from the veils of the morning
to where the cricket sings their
midnights all a glimmer and noon a
purple glow and evening full of the
linen's wings
i will arise and go now for always night
and day i hear lake water lapping with
low sounds by the shore
while i stand on the roadway or on the
pavement's gray i hear it in the deep
heart's core
note that ending which wasn't there in
the first version he wrote about 18
months before then it ends much more
limply but he ends the poem with those
three strong beats the deep hearts core
which i think is something he learned
again from gaelic poetry it's very much
a gaelic meter he not reading irish he
didn't learn directly from that but he
learned it from the translations that
were being made from gaelic poetry by
people he admired like samuel ferguson
um
i love that poem i think it always works
yates grew to hate it because he had to
recite it so often someone
spotted him i think hugh kingsmill
describes seeing him
recite it at some hotel in switzerland
where he noticed him giving a reading
with an air of suppressed loathing
there's a
there's also a wonderful letter i found
in kansas from somebody asking
permission for innisfree to be set to
music so it could be sung by four
thousand boy scouts in the open air
and um
yates has annotated this letter okay
given the permission and then he's just
written in brackets in the margin poor
island
which i think is
is is is lovely and that um that
personal touch is opposite too because
what he found in that poem was personal
utterance as he called it he decided his
poetry up to then was too cloudy too
directionless he's only 25 remember it
was too much about the worlds that he
imagined and not the worlds he knew and
innisfree is
a turning point because it's concrete
personal utterance which would be at the
center of his poetry i think of his best
poetry certainly from then
on
there's a nice little piece of ancillary
evidence too again a letter written long
after he died by his sister lily who um
wrote wonderful letters to an adoptive
daughter really who's a niece in new
zealand and she's suddenly in the middle
of a letter sometime in the 1940s which
i was reading in a slightly you know
just in case way she describes
remembering an evening in the house in
bedford park and she said willie
bursting into the room
while i was sitting there
painting with our friend helen and he
read to us or he brought forth as she
puts it in his free
and she just knew that this was
greatness and she could hear the lake
water lapping and then at the end her
friend just looked up and asked if she
could borrow a paintbrush she hadn't
listened to a word and you have this
feeling of the wings of
history of literary history anyway
beating over your head and greatness
noticed but also unnoticed
um
at the same time
as
personal utterances discovered in the
circles of london bohemia yates is
living at a time of revolution i've
described one kind of revolution which
is the social revolution the rising
catholic middle classes displacing the
kind of privileged
people from whom the yates family came
their reaction to this is interesting
because the yates family his immediate
family become nationalists now most of
their friends and relations don't and
they see them in a sense as sort of
class traitors but they're strong home
rulers and yates will become something
more radical than that he'll become
athenian as it's called revolutionary he
grows up
against a background of political change
and he is determined that even though he
comes from what has been a unionist
protestant upper middle class background
he's determined that he will not be
marginalized from what's happening to
ireland
over and over again he says in this
first half of his life ireland is being
made or remade and those who have the
power of imagination must grasp us and
must participate in it and it comes i
must stress again from a class who are
in a sense turning their backs on a lot
of what's going on yates and a few of
his friends are determined to be
implicated in what's happening the slow
revolution of
land of the change of
landed power the faster revolution of
the shift in political influence which
in the end becomes a real revolution and
he becomes involved in the so-called
fenian movement secret pledge-bound
conspiratorial
um movement he's associated with it
quite closely for 10 years and he writes
poems in the 1890s like to ireland in
the coming times which are making a very
direct political statement about
marginalization he's saying in a poem
like that look
i can be an irish protestant i can be
non-gaelic i can be non-catholic i can
actually believe in the occult but that
can make me a better nationalist
than any of you
know that i would account to be true
brother of that company who sang to
sweden ireland's wrong ballad and story
ran and song nor be i any less of them
because the red rose bordered hem of her
whose history began before god made the
angelic clan trails all about the
written page for in the world's first
blossoming age the lightfall of her
flying feet made ireland's heart begin
to beat and still the starry candles
flare to help her lightfoot here and
there and still the thoughts of ireland
brood upon her holy quietude
and he's saying that he understands
ireland because of his occultist his
spiritualist his supernatural
predilections
he who treads in austere ways may surely
meet their ancient gays
and he is also addressing this poem not
only
to ireland in the coming times but he's
addressing it to mod gone the woman with
whom he is in love i cast my heart into
my rhymes that you in the dim coming
times may know how my heart went with
them
after the red rose bordered hem
so once again you have a poem doing two
jobs the eight's poems operate on many
levels and very often poems that one
doesn't think of as love poems are love
poems the same i think is true of easter
1916 which i'll come to a little later
and the subject is usually not always
but usually mod gone famously beautiful
fiery
uncompromising nationalist propagandist
actually english but becomes more irish
than the irish brought as he said the
troubling of his life to him his family
who
never liked her referred to her
privately as the infernal mod
and um again the invaluable sisters
diary describes when mode gone first
came to call on the eights is that she
she kept her slippers on all the time
and kept the cab waiting the yates were
poor enough to know that to keep a cab
waiting meant um that you didn't have
financial worries
um yates was
obsessed by her he tried to win her much
i think of his advanced nationalist
political activity was directed towards
her but she was always effortlessly more
advanced than he was and she was as he
later wrote complete and i was not she
had also achieved completion early on
she was a woman who did not change her
mind and he writes about this over and
over again
um he begged her to marry him she told
him she was sworn to a life of
dedication to ireland in any case she
told them they were astrally related
because in a previous existence they'd
been brother and sister which put a very
useful
um
sort of incest block
on the um
on the on the procedure so he wrote her
poems instead which they both referred
to as their children
as lady gregory would refer to the plays
they worked on together as their
children so there's something going on
on another level here all the time and
the poems he wrote mod gone are some of
the most famous love poems ever written
the cloths of heaven always high on the
list of all-time favorites had i the
heavens embroidered cloths and wrought
with golden and silver light the blue
and the dim and the dark cloths of night
and light and the half-light i would
spread the cloths under your feet but i
being poor have only my dreams i've
spread my dreams under your feet tread
softly because you tread on my dreams
it was
slightly different she didn't put
crudely fancy dates although they did
eventually sleep together but she was
not dedicated solely to ireland she had
been involved with an older man in
france for years she had had two
children by him she didn't believe in
marriage she was a new woman as they
called it then and a true radical she
had a life of her own which he didn't
reveal to yates for 10 years
and he
revealed it to him under circumstances
of great trauma in 1898
and then just when he was getting used
to this she turned around and married
someone else
a red-headed utterly unintellectual
irish revolutionary hero who made her
very unhappy they split up 12 years
later he fought in the 1916 irish rising
and was executed
through all of this their friendship
endured and one of the interesting
things working on yates is how women
become and remain his friends whether or
not he has affairs with them he sustains
friendship in a very
egalitarian way with a number of
strong-minded and interesting and
talented women
but maud gone is always at the center of
his emotional life this came i have to
admit as
a slight surprise to me i had decided
when i began all this that there was a
certain
contrivance about all this how useful i
thought if you're a young and poor poet
determined on greatness how useful to
fall in love with uh dramatically
unattainable
princess 10
who will not marry you who lives in
paris conveniently a lot of the time who
will not make you go and live in the
suburbs and have a day job and two
children
and i thought that the poems with poems
like the white birds which are so
perfect in the
patina of their effect must come from
a calculation as well as a passion but
reading his unpublished work reading his
drafts his horoscope calculations his
accounts of dreams which he kept
endlessly even long before he began
reading jung whom he read very early he
was recording all his dreams you just
have to recognize a major obsession and
it's perhaps most clearly portrayed not
in what i call the gleaming surface the
patina of his famous love poems but
really in his drafts in his scribbles in
in in a prose idea for a poem called
subject for lyric which is in one of his
notebooks where he
writes of her coming to sit in his room
by the railway station by houston
railway station on her way to france
taking off her hat rearranging her hair
in the mirror and he says you play with
me with images of marriage which you
will not give me and it's a very
uh it's a thing anyone could have felt
it's not about white birds and spreading
cloths of heaven under his beloved's
feet it's it's a real cry from the heart
it's more ordinary and therefore i think
more moving
and to work through yates's drafts
because he begins often with an ordinary
idea and then builds it up in his
notebooks with imagery often
culled from ideas or notes he's made
years before into one of the astonishing
combinations which is best poetry is
gone keeps recurring because there's
another bond between them which reflects
on something carl mentioned auden's
comments on the aids auden was very
always very clever about yates
um sometimes rather [ __ ] but always
very clever i uh treasure a
limerick just comes into mind that's not
relevant what i'm about to say about
of ordinance on the eights which is
something like to get the late poems of
yates you need not mug up any dates all
the reader requires is some knowledge of
gyres and the kind of people he hates
which is
which is actually a very good guide to
to lady aids but he also odin wrote off
yates's occult supernatural interests he
called it the south californian side of
yates and um
this was a fashionable thing to do 20 or
30 years ago
it was foolish and silly and you just
tried to ignore it for embarrassment's
sake and get on with it
you can't do that because it's one of
the central
bulwarks of yates's spiritual
imaginative and i would argue emotional
life
he believed in the occult world he spent
his life trying to find arcane truths
through the study of magic he
joined orders of mystical initiates he
spent a large amount of money and time
chasing up um
ghosts of one kind or another traveling
to seances
seeking out spiritualists investigating
occult phenomena why
mord gone is one reason she too was a
convinced believer and he made this an
area where he could
if not control her at least be her her
guide they wanted to form a secret
mystical celtic order together as order
of poets and visionaries which would i
think replace religion they prospected
around ireland for a place where this
secret order would begin yates rather
pathetically writes to her that he hopes
it can be done for 30 shillings a week
um
marge didn't have to worry about money
in the same way he did they exchange
visions
when they're apart they try and have
simultaneous dreams which have a very
sexual content metaphorically speaking
the language of these is straight
freudianism really
they're inspired
partly chemically because they take
masculine and hashish together but
partly also from a wide variety of
reading in the kabbalah and the wisdom
of the tarot and all those other things
that were very fashionable in the 1880s
and 90s as they are once again very
fashionable remember yates is an 1890s
decadent but he's also an art student in
the 1880s
and some things never change art
students among them
um
but he can use the occult
sensors to bring his influence to bear
on people to dominate clubs and circles
even to educate himself i see it as a
kind of do-it-yourself university
complete with reading lists uh degrees
that you pass through
lectures
quarrels that make university department
quarrels look mild factions
and all the time the idea that you're
proceeding through levels of knowledge
to a qualification which will give you
authority and that is why i've called my
first volume the apprentice mage because
i think he is determined to learn how to
be a magician
i've also as a historian looked in this
in a slightly different way and i found
i think a long tradition of marginalized
irish protestant figures who are
interested in the occult going back to
charles maturin who wrote melmoth the
wanderer sheridan lefeneux who invented
lesbian vampires and even bram stoker
who comes from exactly the same
background as yates declining irish
clerical protestant bourgeoisie i could
talk a little more about dracula as an
absentee irish landlord if you like but
i won't um i do think that yates uses
his belief in the occult and in fairy
lore to demonstrate a claim on ireland
to claim the land of ireland again to
say look i may come from a tradition
that the nationalist
vogue
writes off as being on irish but
actually through my
links through my knowledge through my
identification of ireland's occult
supernatural
other world i am more irish than any of
you
this of course was unpopular with
conventional irish opinion and he spent
his life being criticized for it notably
by catholic clerics
and he takes up a confrontational and
public stance especially when in his
theater the abbey theater he begins or
well from the very beginning he is
trying to put on drama which will
express some of these themes
and it's not coincidental again that
yates adopts his confrontational
approach to the irish theater and to the
kind of plays he wants to put on when
mod gone has married someone else when
they've drifted apart a little when he
is
becoming disillusioned i'm talking about
1902 1903 with conventional irish
nationalism and he decides that the
theater will be
like a sort of secret society where the
artist will officiate like a kind of
priest presenting avant-garde and
inspirational art
to an audience who will be united by us
he his favorite quotation about this is
if i come from victor google in the
theater a mob becomes a people by
concentrating on a visionary
presentation people are welded together
and this of course has very strong
national and nationalist implications
wagner is thinking in a not dissimilar
way at this very time
it didn't work out quite like that and
yates was constantly embattled within
and without because what he wanted to
put on stage in the abbey theater was
considered by conventional irish
nationalism notably by the new sinn fein
movement from 1904 was considered
not really um
acceptable
the theater of course did become famous
it was the crucible for talents like jm
singh and sean o'casey but it didn't put
on work at least yates didn't want to
put on work that would fit the pious
image of nationalist ireland as
conceived by sinn fein and one reason
why he loved and defended singing his
plays notably the playboy of the western
world was because it
subverted piety and his beautiful poem
the fisherman which is about an ideal
irish audience is i think an elegy for
sing as well as an attack on his irish
enemies
i think it's very likeable in yates
to be so in favor of sing who is a great
playwright because yates's own players
sent people away from theater in droves
um
the very few exceptions always have
something special about them
one is his nationalist
um
really allegory play kathleen nevuland
which he wrote with lady gregory which
lady gregory in her diary says which i
wrote all but all of but which was put
out under yates's more famous name in
which maud gone acted mesmerically and
people went wild about it
um it's interesting
that lady gregory is involved in this
she's a fascinating character who
becomes in fact more republican than he
ate more nationalists than he ate i
think as time goes
on and she's the other great female
relationship in his life besides mod
gone she's some people have spoken of
her as a surrogate
parent figure to him but i don't think
that's right she she's remembered
inaccurately as a sort of queen victoria
figure little and dumply and dressed in
black and a kind of professional widow
actually she wasn't at all like that she
had
several affairs with younger men she was
a powerful and interesting and
interventionist character she was
determined as yates was to become an
artist and did
and
she through willpower because she had
very little money she did turn her home
cool park
into a
salon for some of the most interesting
writers of the renaissance and she
devoted her great energies and talents
to the adi theater and kept it going
when
yates alone could not have done so
and his relationship with lady gregory
whom he meets at a very low point in his
life in the 1890s is very interesting
because he writes to her about
everything in his life but he puts a
spin on it
that as we all do that he thinks his
recipient will
will most react to
and he writes to her in the persona i
think of the kind of person he thinks
she wants him to be
and over the gosh
40 odd years of their relationship he
becomes something like the kind of
person he thinks she wants to be it's a
very jamesian sort of
procedure
and
she gives him a lot but he gives her a
lot
and one of the things he gives her is
a great poetic gift which are the
elegies he writes for her beloved only
son robert who is killed in the first
world war and again one of these poems
that seems simple but
must be put in context for its true
complexity and cleverness and almost
deviousness to be
spotted
an irish airman foresees his death i
know that i shall meet my fate somewhere
among the clouds above those that i
fight i do not hate those that i guard i
do not love
my country is kill tartan cross my
countrymen kill tarpon's poor no likely
end could bring them loss or leave them
happier than before nor law nor duty bad
mephite nor public men nor sharing
crowds a lonely impulse of delight drove
to this tumult in the clouds
i balanced all brought all to mind the
years to come seemed waste of breath a
waste of breath the years behind in
balance with this life this death
which sounds a very nihilistic and
rather a moral view of why you go off
and fight and kill people but you must
remember it's 1918
the easter rising has happened two years
before people who were fighting for
britain were not looked on kindly by
nationalist ireland in 1918. what this
poem is saying besides establishing
gregory as a figure of sprezzatura and
almost
offhand
um
nihilism in a way
besides doing that which is utterly um
um
inaccurate because robert greger was
actually very imperially minded and
fought i think with an absolute sense of
who he was fighting for besides doing
that it's saying
it's okay for him to have been killed
fighting for britain
because he didn't really mean it
he was doing it in this offhand way he
knew exactly that he was irish that his
identifications went to the village at
the gates of his mother's house
and that
that's why he did it so he can be
mourned as a true irishman not as a
soldier in the
service of the evil empire
so there's again a political a very
clever political twist to be decoded
there
by then of course gates himself is
a fairly hard-line nationalist in the
years after 1916. but this has required
some reinsertion of himself back into
the the the tradition of irish
nationalism because in fact what his
writing up to 19
certainly 1914-15 is remarkable for is a
disillusionment
an estrangement as he called it from
irish nationalism and i think i think
biographers sometimes do
is to try and choose
or they find themselves choosing a piece
of work by their subject which acts as a
pivot
for a whole change in consciousness
element does this wonderfully with
joyce's short story of the dead which he
takes as an absolute explication really
of a catharsis in his life if i've done
anything like that in the volume that
i've completed it's with an essay called
jm singh and the ireland of his time
which yates wrote
technically as an elegy in memory of
seeing in 1910 but really as an
explanation for why he hates had to
separate from conventional irish
nationalism which he says now is
forbidding intellectual experiment and
the key
moment when this happened was when sinn
fein got the audiences to riot against
singh's great play the playboy of the
western world and when yates as he says
stood there watching knowing that i saw
the dissolution of a school of
patriotism that held sway over my youth
and he goes on to construct an argument
in this 1910 essay
which is against the pressures of
national conformity which is to say
ireland is now culturally independent
enough not to need the as he calls them
images for the affections not to need
the confining stereotypes
of old-style nationalism he said we must
now be a modern country and that means
experiment in art and allowing
experiment in art we now he said have
the world's ear thanks for history to
the work of himself and his generation
and it's an essay an autobiography
masquerading i think as an elegy for his
dead friend but between 1913 and 1916 as
irish politics become revolutionized as
world war one comes along as
revolutionary conspiracy gathers there's
a failed rising revolution in 1916 a
draconian british reaction
and
opinion shifts
the people who've made the revolution
are in fact the generation whom yates
has been quarreling that shin feigners
who
criticize his work who have attacked
singh's plays they include people like
maud guns estranged husband john mcbride
but when yates decides to memorialize
the 1916 rising in his i think great
poem eastern 1916 he does so by
memorializing these very people
and by reinserting himself and his
generation of cultural experimenters in
the 90s into
the process of irish political
revolution which isn't quite right he'd
become marginalized from all this years
before 1916 but by arguing as he does
incessantly from them to the end of his
life that the cultural revolution he put
into
um
gear after parnell's death in 1891
produced the 1916 rising he has made
himself a political
founding father you can follow the
procedure in his letters after he hears
of the 1916 rising and as he changes his
mind about its significance and he
changes his his preoccupations and the
result is one of his great poems easter
1916 which immortalizes the refrain all
is changed utterly a terrible beauty is
born he apostrophizes the heroes of the
revolution but there's a central
ambiguity in it and interestingly it's
the same ambiguity that is in his great
sing essay of 1910 and if you read the
notes for that sing essay you find the
images notably of a stone fixed in the
stream of life which he will use in the
eastern 1916 poem it owes as much to his
thoughts in 1910 as to his reactions in
1916 and after apostrophizing the
heroism of the revolutionary generation
after his own he writes
hearts with one purpose alone through
summer and winter seem enchanted to a
stone to trouble the living stream
the horse that comes from the road the
rider the birds that range from cloud to
tumbling cloud minute by minute they
change a shadow of cloud on the stream
changes minute by minute a horse hoof
slides on the brim and a horse clashes
within it the long-legged moorhens dive
and hens to morcox call minute by minute
they live the stones in the midst of all
too long a sacrifice can make a stone of
the heart or when may it suffice and
that goes right back to that sing essay
where he had prophetically said that
minds whose patriotism was great enough
to carry them to the scaffold cry down
natural impulse with the morbid
persistence of minds unsettled by some
fixed idea and you've gone on to write
that a generation was becoming like a
hysterical woman who makes unmeasured
accusations and believes in possible
things because of a logical deduction
which has turned a portion of her mind
to stone
no prizes for saying
guessing who he was thinking of so in a
sense eastern 1916 is a love poem to mod
gone and it makes further sense to know
that he rode while he finished it
staying with her in her house in france
he stayed up all one night to finish it
he read it to her standing on the beach
the next morning during their walk
um he asked her to marry him again the
the composition of this poem is as built
up with that great recurring
relationship as it is with the political
events it purports to describe
and the the the stands i read about the
flux of life this stony heart at the
center of it the the macing of morcox
and moorhens going on around this
beautiful image of a horse splashing to
a stream is about his attempt to make
her join him in a more
normal conventional married relationship
as usual he failed to please her she
didn't like the poem she sent him a long
and rather marvelous letter beginning no
willy i do not like your poem in which
she denied as a good catholic that
sacrifice had ever turned anything to
stone but there she is again in a poem
which doesn't seem to be
about her
as for him he's back with advanced
nationalism again he writes famous poems
and less famous plays pressing the
nationalist cause he becomes as i've
said at the beginning of this lecture
a famous public figure in a newly
independent ireland he speaks out on
issues of civil religious liberty but he
always fights with established authority
and i'll in conclusion i'll anticipate a
little my next volume because what
happens by the early 1930s is that he is
so disillusioned that he has a fling
with right-wing politics and i think
this feeds directly into the way he
writes because in the last decade of his
life in the 1930s he writes more and
more originally and more and more
angrily and he rails against old age
loss of sexual potency which he tries to
reverse by slightly crazy operation as
well as several love affairs and he
becomes a great and controversial irish
institution
his last poems were thought by many to
be incomprehensible but they now seem
his greatest and poems like long-legged
fly
seem to anticipate the threat to
civilization which is coming
to anticipate more eloquently than ever
and what this poem written in this late
period shows i think is how he can move
across centuries of history and art and
mythology with a brilliant economy from
the roman empire to helen of troy to the
sistine chapel and i think it's the mark
of the auto dialect the self-taught
poverty stricken art student in
hammersmith as well as of the genius
that he's unafraid to tackle these
great almost too obvious instances of
cultural history
they also demonstrate i think that
jungian interest in archetypes which
never left
that civilization may not sink its great
battle lost quiet the dog tether the
pony to a distant post
our master caesar is in his tent where
the maps are spread his eyes fixed upon
nothing a hand under his head like a
long-legged fly upon the stream his mind
moves upon silence that the topless
towers be burnt and men recall that face
move most gently if move you must in
this lonely place
she thinks part woman three parts a
child that nobody looks her feet
practice a tinker shuffle picked up on a
street like a long legged fly upon the
stream her mind moves upon silence
that girls at puberty may find the first
adam in their thought shut the door of
the pope's chapel keep those children
out
there on that scaffolding reclines
michelangelo with no more sound than the
mice make his hand moves to and fro
like a long-legged fly upon the stream
his mind moves upon silence
yates dies in 1939 in the south of
france controversial even in death and
there's one wonderful obituary by an old
friend and a sparring partner stephen
gwynne who always said he didn't like
yates
but had to write about him
and gwyn's
obituary which hasn't i think been
quoted before
or since it was written went
first and last he was smashing idols in
the marketplace
at first the cheap rhetoric of drum
beating ballads false models and poetry
later justifying work which his artistic
sense approved as vital while the crowd
denounced it as an insult to ireland
first and last he was a champion of
freedom but above all against the
tyrannies of democracy
and in the end the democracy which he
never spared to resist and rebuke
marches to its credit behind his coffin
yates of course had to have the last
word so he wrote his own obituary
in a poem called under ben bolden
and is rather different from that tone
many times man lives and dies between
his two eternities that of race and that
of soul and ancient ireland knew it all
whether man dies in his bed or the rifle
knocks him dead a brief parting from
those dear is the worst man has to fear
though gravediggers toil is long sharp
their spades their muscles strong they
but thrust their buried men back in the
human mind again
in this as in all his life autobiography
is being threaded through and his occult
his ideas his beliefs are there in that
simple valid meter
as you all know you can't bank on the i
the personal voice in any poem being
that of the poet it's one of the great
misleading devices
of poets who are ventriloquists
but with yates the eye is often a
personal eye
and you may have noticed how many of the
poems i've read begin with the word i
a poet he said writes out of his
personal life always which is why it's
important to study his biography another
sanction and from my point of view why
it's important to write it on scale
which hasn't been attempted before
at the same time his imagination is
fabulous as james joyce said joyce said
no one could equal no surrealist poet
could equal yates's imagination
his occult studies his strange reading
provide those astonishing images in in a
poem let's say like sailing to byzantium
images that range from a mackerel
crowded sea to a bird of hammered gold
singing on a tree
and this kind of imagery can lead you
astray he's trying to construct a
passion he's trying to dazzle you even
when he puts a date at the end of a poem
it might not be the date the poem was
written
this was a horror to me when i slowly
realized
but essentially it all goes back into
his
astonishing life love sex politics
occultism and he tells us this in one of
those great last poems the last one i'll
read part of the circus animal's
desertion where he describes the themes
that have preoccupied him and he ends
those masterful images because complete
grew in pure mind but out of what began
a mound of refuse or the sweepings of a
street old kettles old bottles and a
broken can
old iron old bones old rags that raving
[ __ ] who keeps the tail
now that my ladder's gone i must lie
down where all the ladders start in the
foul rag and bone shot of the heart
and his
genius his inspiration are here seen as
a ladder to ascend from the everyday
circumstances of life eliot in fact to
return to him in conclusion admit it as
much when he said that you couldn't
understand yates's times as i've said
without reading his poetry and couldn't
equally understand yates's poetry unless
you knew a bit about the history against
which he wrote his poems and that
goes for public general history as well
as personal history in fact i think it's
one of the reasons why his poetry not
only lives but grows in stature
doing justice to it involves
understanding the full historical
complexity of yates's life and such an
understanding such tracing the lineage
as yet
as it happens does justice to ireland's
complex history as well
thank you
thank you if there are questions i'm
happy to take some
yes
they're hard to do because
the early ones are hard to do because he
he dreamt of enormous scenic effects
there's a wonderful correspondence
gordon craig the great experimenter of
the
sort of fantasy period and he hates
wanted effects that nowadays you
probably could do actually with lighting
and scene changes but which were very
hard to do in his own day and it's only
late in his life i was talking about
this car actually exactly the subject
before electric that is only late in his
life he gets it right i think in short
economical plays like the words upon the
window pane and purgatory both which
have actually been revived very recently
in london and quite successfully
they're also
more accessibly written i think they the
kind of occult
charge of the the earlier kukulen plays
and the slightly creaky political
symbolism of some of them like the
king's threshold which is about
censorship and the place of the artist
while you could see them
being
being updated rather relevantly in
certain societies look a bit um
a bit irrelevant now i keep waiting for
somebody to start
reinterpreting them and they they have
the whole column play cycle has been
done in dublin by um
directed by james flannery from from
atlanta in fact
uh for the last three years but i have
to say i don't think they've been an
unqualified
success
what did marriage provide her for him
well i've been asked how central to
yates's life what dawn was and what
marriage provided for um and i've tried
a way to show she is very central to his
imagination and to his emotional
being
and um
in a way she's central both in
giving him
a great image to live for and a great
uh ideal to follow but she's also
central in i'm sure unintentionally
making him confront what she conceives
of as his own inadequacies because when
she does for instance marry a an
unintellectual man of action i think he
feels
very
wrong-footed
and
his whole public stance especially he
goes to america interesting the first
time just after this bombshell bursts on
and his whole quarrelsome public
aggressive hyper-masculine stance in
america i think owes a great deal to the
shop she's just dalton as to marriage um
he married a woman much younger than he
who shared his occult interests who was
like all his women friends extremely
strong-minded intelligent and
independent which was as well for her
and she
provided him with a home
with some money because she had a
private income she guarded his health
she also allowed him his freedom
which was very important and she was
known mean critic um i've seen left as a
person back very recently in yale where
she she writes to a friend of hers about
the poetry he's writing the late
twenties and she says some of it i think
v remarkable some of it
somewhere is it rubbish
she uses some terribly dismissive words
i was shocked and then i thought well
she may not be all together wrong at
that point because he was writing very
freely and very um
at that time too so she also brought i
think a fine critical edge and she kept
the yates estate the literary estate
really in
what people scholars complained about
the chaotic state of the archives in 50s
and 60s but that didn't matter the point
was she kept the stuff and he threw out
stuff she kept it she did keep it i
think fairly well in order and she
she knew the importance of her editorial
task sorry there is another question
you mentioned the difficulty of
yates list dating his poems i wonder if
you could talk about what some of the
other most difficult challenges of
writing yates's life
have been
uh the handwriting was the first one
which um because he was terribly bad
eyesight and was nearly blind at certain
points in his life so his handwriting is
frightful and he begins dictating
letters
um quite early on and that puts a filter
between what he's
saying and thinking i think and what is
what's appearing on the page because you
know he's dictating something to a
typist in a room near the british museum
and he's certainly not going to wear his
heart on his sleeve and that it also
means he writes these endless letters
because they're dictated so you have to
look at a yates letter very carefully to
see what how it was
made and what it's doing and very often
the most important stuff would be a
scribble post script at the end which
was too confidential for the typers so
the
the decoding of yates documents
presents all sorts of
special difficulties though they are
difficulties historians are trained to
cope with um
the
methods of composition which i had hoped
not to have to worry too much about
because of the great corpus of literary
criticism are something i do have to
worry about because i did realize as i
said in the lecture that his notes for
poems often are as biographically
important as what he
eventually ends up saying on the printed
page so to reassemble the various drafts
of something i'm very interested to play
the player queen for instance isn't a
very good play but it's one of those
things he took a very long time
writing
um and re-drafting and i think grows out
of certain relationships he had in the
theater notably with a woman called
mabel dickinson we had a love affair
with for about four years from 1909
so and forever finding another down-able
draft of the player queen that i didn't
know existed and i'm trying to
find out or decide at what point he made
those changes
um
something
is true in the same way of a much better
play the countess kathleen which he
begins before he meets mod gone but
which he then in various drafts turns
into i think a more gone play and morgan
becomes i think
the contest and of the figure of this uh
barred minstrel uh
lover or person in love with the contest
becomes more and more important and of
course this is yates and that
relationship begins to take central
place in the plague which originally was
about something else altogether so one
of the difficulties is having to
learn the tools if you like of textual
criticism to turn them to a
biographer's
use
but um the more you do it the more
addictive it gets um the main just to
end this answer the main problem is the
sheer
weight and volume of material all over
the world and the um
the difficulty of of physically reading
something
yes
i just wondered if
you talked about yates and theater
if
there's you've come through so much
material have you ever read
and or seen a piece a theater piece
about yates
and also if you could go back in time
you can see it's the performer
live what would you want to see him do
i mean i'm sure you've come through
someone like a speech or a lecture or
something that you thought i wish i
could be there and see
i think i'd like to see him
take on the the abbey
audiences
writing or complaining or
demonstrating against an okc or singing
play and i'd like to have heard him
address them from the stage because i
i've listened to all those recordings
and reading
the poetry and sometimes it's wonderful
and sometimes it isn't because he has
this strange ear
utterly on musical couldn't learn
foreign languages composed out loud in
order to get a rhythm
and he reads them in this very stagey
way which often loses i think the inner
the inner assonance of the line
plays about yates i it's it's an
interesting question i think one of
yates's best plays is as i said the
words from the window pane which is a
play about swift and of some swift
coming through a medium's voice and if
somebody wrote a play like that about
yates it would indeed be very
interesting but he's not terribly easy
to
to dramatize i'm surprised it's just i
mean you have things about wild and you
know yeah
it will be it will be done i mean i know
that someone has the option on a film
about mod gone's life for instance which
is obviously a figure there's a question
just in front there yes could you uh uh
explain uh uh more about the uh uh the
image or the metaphor of the winding
staircase as a as a kind of uh symbol
for human progress and uh and as does
the gates allow uh made any allowance
for those of us who seem to be going
down the staircase rather than
um
i can't really be very profound about
this i think the notion of a tower and
the stair going up
is something that he's had from very
early on he has it when he has a sort of
vision of arie hustow when he's in italy
he's walking
along a road
and this is what this is 1907.
in the twilight and he sees a tower with
an outside staircase going up to it and
he has a terrifically powerful vision of
a poet's place being up at the top of
that tower having ascended the staircase
looking out the window and this of
course
predicts by
gosh by 21 years his great volume of
verse the tower which is based for its
central image on his own tower that he
bought near lady gregory's medieval
castle with the staircase
the winding of the stair is obviously
associated with the idea of gyres of
spirals of interconnecting spirals
um and i suppose the notion of a spiral
is that you're ascending but you can't
see what's ahead of you can't see what's
around the corner
um i think that the idea of
development
but
being necessarily in
in ignorance of what remains at the end
of what's around
the next corner is something he refers
to time and time again
never more epigrammatically than in a
very late letter where he says man can
embody truth but not note
and i think that that idea of being
unable to see what's
directly ahead is is to do with the
spiral the spire of the movement
um but
i'm just moving on to the period of his
life where he writes a vision which of
course is all about these kind of ideas
so i'll answer that question
for six months time
yes
i was very interested in the uh
reversion
in april 1916
to uh support for the people that in a
way he had set in motion earlier but
since
distanced himself from a kind of a
grandfathering of himself
and uh yeah grand pondering also before
this word
came to be used in new york real estate
but
um
you know like seamus haney's
late
writing about
the troubles or
i mean is there a
an echo or a pre
post echo now of
art for art's sake versus pc that we see
in so many
artists i mean the argument now in new
york is it's very hard not to have some
pc content in arts
uh yates in a way sort of um
is it relevant this this
this moment of yates relevant to our
yeah i'm not quite sure that i put in
pc terms i'd put it into her if pc
stands for political commitment
um perhaps i know it doesn't but i mean
that's
i would take it as that and i would say
that yates like all irish artists
operates against a highly politicized
background like all irish artists and
heaney himself has said this um you're
trying to balance the claims
that
an audience which is you know embroiled
in politics makes upon you and the
necessary independence which an artist
has to try and
work from yates's astonishing to me
achievement is that his political poems
no matter how political remain somehow
in a way above politics to partly
because of what i was saying earlier
about the two levels at least two levels
that they always work on on the one hand
you'll get a simple
or not simple but uh uh a lyric like
wandering angus which you think isn't
about politics i think in a sense it is
on the other hand you'll get very direct
fenian political poems like the rose
tree poems which are also i think about
occult and supernatural imagery as well
as being about sacrificial revolutionary
politics and in a sense he is providing
by
by observing those two functions he's
providing you with an alternative level
on which to to to
uh um decode or respond
if the direct politics of it don't
particularly appeal to you eastern 1916
does this
i think more complexly almost than any
other poem he writes which is one reason
why i find it very fascinating
um seamus heaney's
way of handling irish politics i always
remember when i read north for the first
time used to be in the early 1970s and
it surprised me that people weren't
writing as they weren't incredible it
may seem much about
northern irish politics then and when i
read north
those wonderful images of the bog and
history and all the rest of it i thought
so this is how it can be written about i
remember thinking that
um he needs i think his
his great recent collection was not that
reason now it's station island
has political poems in it as well which
very interestingly mixed the
supernatural with the political
there's that long poem of visions of
people against william carlton and then
a relative of his who has shot and
appears as a ghost
to him and it's again doing this
highly devious and highly intelligent
thing of writing a political
poem while leaving a latitude for
interpretation which doesn't box the
poet into being the voice of one faction
or the other while you know the
tradition from which he writes
sorry it's rather complex answers um i
think it's a very interesting question
it's a good question
first part
did he ever acknowledge his english
heritage
or background and did he write in a
romance in any kind of romanticized form
about the descendancy
of the uh the english landed class in
ireland that's the first part and the
second part is can you talk a little bit
about the term celtic twilight because
when i first heard about it i thought of
twilight as being kind of the end of
something
but perhaps the term twilight is used in
a different way well you're absolutely
right i'll answer the second question
first which is the meaning of celtic
twilight yates makes it very specific
and so does george russell ae who was
one of his great friends and who
also a great figure in the
in in the celtic revival they made it
very clear that for them twilight was
the hour before the dawn which had all
sorts of occult
um um
suggestiveness and twilight meant a
predawn thing not the fading off of
something but because we so generally
use twilight as meaning the end of the
day that's what it's assumed to be but
actually they
were concerned to emphasize that it was
that witching hour just before the sun
rises um and in fact
ae has painted a painting called the
celtic twilight which is currently on
exhibit in yale at the british art
center so
the other day which is two people
bending over a well out of which this
blaze of light is coming and i think
it's meant to represent the well of
kamala which is is is an idea an irish
mythology of a well where everlasting
life and wisdom comes from and the sky
above them is
raining down light as well and it's
obviously the dawn is about to rise and
it's called the celtic twilight so
that's a very concrete um
example of it the other question you ask
about yates's recognition of his english
inheritance that's
on two levels he is always
very conscious of and is much criticized
by irish nationalists for this he's very
conscious of the importance to him and
to any other he would have said educated
person of the great tradition of english
literature
he has been educated and grown up in the
english language whether that was
desirable or not it is how he is he
thinks that the irish have put a special
twist and value and valencia and
and flexibility into their writing in
the english language which is a great
achievement
he says he owes his soul to spencer and
william morris and shakespeare and
milton and byron and shelly you know the
whole grand tradition and deliberately i
think mentioning spencer whom he adores
but who of course was
a planter in ireland and a brutal one
and um wrote uh
texts for the british government in the
16th century suggesting very brutal
measures against irish natives yates can
separate that from spencer's astonishing
and to him very inspirational poetic
voice but at the same time he says in a
marvelous piece of writing that was
published posthumously called a general
introduction to my work he says that
though he owes his soul to these
this this this great tradition at the
same time in everyday political
circumstances and in the kind of fenian
politics which he's been involved he is
of course on some levels anti-english
and my love tortures me with hate my
hate with love he says but at the same
time he spends an awful lot of time in
england many of his best friends most of
his lovers his wife indeed are all
english and his descent
is another matter his family have been
in ireland for three or four hundred
years you know they go back a long way
and
some of them to
french um
roots rather than english so there's not
at all a recent english import he's
he wouldn't use the word anglo irish of
his family nor should it be thus used
you know they've been rooted there a
long time but they
their origins go back to
settlements
in in the 17th century in some cases but
right back to the 12th century in the
case of the butlers to whom he is also
related and he's very conscious of that
tradition and he in a sense rediscovers
it in the 1920s when he's a senator in
the free state when he becomes
disillusioned with the way irish
politics seem to be going with the
ascendancy of people whom he thinks are
uncultured
and he begins very aggressively
expounding the virtues and the values of
the ascendancy tradition of burke of
gratton of of the great 18th century
figures in in irish life this is not a
popular line to pursue in the late 1920s
but that's all the more um
attractive to him whenever he's
just finally a way in which he's very
good it's the same trick he does in his
poetry of politics working on another
level as well he even when he makes a
political speech on a very
we'll say pc um irish nationalist line
like that home rule must come he will
give a reason for it which is so
offensive to his audience that you can
tell it's given him a certain pleasure
the one i'm thinking of is a speech
actually in america where he says we
must have home rule in ireland we must
have political autonomy because it will
educate um catholics mentally and
protestants emotionally
so he's um i think it's a wonderful
right and left there which is he's very
good at
maybe one more question that we should
enjoy
okay is there one more here
oh yes uh how do you associate how did
yates associate his right-wing politics
of the 30s with some pretty unsavory uh
sympathizers either in ireland or in
europe
he's not your standard fascist in other
words no he's not he's
he's quite keen on mussolini he spends a
lot of time in italy in the 1920s
staying with us for a pound which isn't
exactly a
good
connection
um he actually goes to italy in the
mid-30s as it gets to the government in
fact um he doesn't
like
what's happening in germany but he won't
put his name to public objections
to it he is pretty
in favor of authoritarian politics i'm
pretty against what he thinks democratic
politics produce
but
when he does have his fling with the
irish right-wing movement the blue
shirts who aren't really fascists
in that sense um but are an
authoritarian old army group who want to
um we'll put the clock back essentially
in terms of irish qualities he it's a
short-lived fling he thinks these are
much cleverer people than they are
fundamentally and he gets deeply
disillusioned when he finds that they're
not reading nietzsche and um ready to
discuss wagner's notion of the position
of the artist in in in modern politics
so he then quite elegantly uh
disconnects himself his wife also to her
credit is very against all this and i
think her influence here as always is is
is important
it should also be said
that though some of his late poems have
a disturbing eugenicist twist and he's
interested in eugenics as many people
are in the 1920s and 30s um he is never
anti-semitic rather the opposite
and i think some of that goes back to
his great commitment to studies in the
cabala
and his belief in
the wisdom of jewish mysticism which he
becomes very interested in the 1890s
um so i think
i can see him being sympathetic to
mussolini but i don't think he was ever
sympathetic to hitler or to nazism as as
such at the same time it would be
dishonest to say not to admit that he
approved of authoritarian politics and
thought that democracy hadn't delivered
well it should but always remember he
died at night early in 1939 you know he
didn't live to see
what was about to happen and he also i
have found rather interesting speeches
again in america where he speaks quite
clearly of his views on democracy but it
seems to me that he's denouncing
democracy in artistic in cultural
matters and at the same time saying that
it can be a political good but that
elitism must rule in in ours
which is not such an
unusual or perhaps not such a disturbing
thing to say
[Applause]
the state university of new york at
oswego is offering a seminar on the
poems of william butler yates from july
6th to july 31st anyone who is
interested should see me
in a moment we'll hear about the history
and operations of the book of the month
club from editor-in-chief greg tobin and
in 20 minutes david darlington discusses
his book about a military research
installation in nevada known as area 51.
if you'd like to order a video copy of
an about books program